today's topic Joe Biden questions
whether or not you're black Joe Biden my
dudes OPA ajp Joe you're not a fan of
sleepy Joe so so if you aren't aware
I'll do you guys the contact leave Joe
Biden was on The Breakfast Club yes for
an interview with Charlemagne the gun
when that's that point Charlemagne said
you know why should people vote for you
something along those lines and Ravi
said listen you gotta come see us when
you come to New York VP Biden well it's
a long way until November we got more
questions you got more questions right
Ellen if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for Mayor Trump and you
ain't black they don't have nothing to
do with Trump it has to do with the fact
I want something for my community I
would love to see you look at my record
man I extended the voting racks 25 years
I have a record that is second to none
the n-double-a-cp s endorsed me every
time I've run the world I mean come on
take a look at the record and then this
went viral here's the thing I love this
comment I was so happy when he said it I
can't tell you how much I jumped for joy
you know people said I can't believe you
said this is the most ridiculous thing
my question to you is house is any more
ridiculous than a politician who comes
on says a whole bunch of promises and
then the next day betrays his whole
constituents if anything you got to
actually hear what Joe Biden really
thinks black people you're going to vote
for me no matter what because if you
don't you're not black those are real
thoughts what people are outraged is
that for once they're getting to see the
real opinion of a politician and it's
ugly and it's disgusting but guess what
the world of politics has always been
disgusting it is always baffled me how
minority groups always fall for a lot of
these politicians who come in their
communities say a few words and then all
of a sudden are like this guy really
gets us I'm just checking yeah I like
that Hillary reference yeah
what's something that you always carry
with you hot sauce really yeah yeah you
get information right now
hot sauce in my bag swag that's us
really yes now that's what I just want
you to know people are gonna see today
okay she's paying her in a black people
okay is it working
it's a huge pet peeve of mine because
here's the thing I think people are
upset at what he said which y'all should
have been upset about is what he didn't
say nowhere in that interview did he
talk about concrete policies no we're in
that interview did he lean on his real
track record to prove that he's actually
been an ally or supporter of African
Americans and so here you are getting
mad at what he did say when the reality
is the importance of what he didn't say
was never there imagine going into a
meeting with a financial adviser and all
he talks about is how your kids are
doing you're not doing your job
let's talk my finances so I'm so happy
that this happened because I'm like
hopefully or people open their eyes
because if you look at his track records
whether it's been slash a social
disability or social security whether
it's been his support for the busing
acts back in the day his track record
with minority communities his tough on
crime policies which is incarcerated so
many black people he's not been an ally
yet everyone has been championing him
and they're like let's go I hate that at
some point we have to acknowledge that
you can't just pick between the lesser
of two evils at some point as you're
voting block you can't look at this and
say i'ma just vote for who's gonna hurt
me the list at some point you have to
consolidate your power and say if you
want me to vote for you if you want us
to vote for you you need to table some
real policies on I need to actually see
what you're gonna do for me now I need
to see that you actually have a track
record to follow through on the promises
that you're going to make if you don't
step away
it angers me I hate seeing politicians
go to a huge Haitian community and sak
pase politicians do it I don't care cuz
they do it here okay in Montreal we have
a big community we have a big Haitian
community in Quebec we have a big
community and so it's a lot of the votes
right so the politicians they're often
gonna do that mm-hmm
I just want to say to all my all my
agents for the words the ones that are
listening to me at the television I just
want to tell you
Napoli bus la TCC pass kay leb a lottery
for new navi day they always do this
it's corny I don't care what hurts me
the most is having all my people being
like Sherman I hate them when they be
jumping because someone is just spin it
spinning I hate that yeah and they've
been doing that and the worst part is
they pander to you they get your vote
super easily and what do they do they
betray the next day you know what it's a
kid - I feel like politicians have a
relationship with black people the same
way a lot of light shift men have with
their girlfriends right so women will
keep coming back don't treat them the
best women will do whatever they want
for the man and they'll help them as
much and the guy's gonna cheat on them
he's gonna do all this stuff and he
knows because he knows that she's not
gonna go anywhere even worse the
knowledge could go anywhere but he takes
out his on them and I think token
politicians have been passing policies
that have negatively impact minority
communities and yet you you line up to
vote for these people who are ready to
betray if it blows my mind it's my
Murray Povich all over again
how so he beats me money from me why are
you so with him because I love him
yo this is us that's us that's what we
do I can't it's time for you to vote for
your interest and if it's not going to
be of a huge benefit to you then
withdraw your vote make them come to you
you see Joe Biden loves to talk he knows
he has black people his pocket so we can
say whatever he wants what does he
always talk about the campaign trail we
have to talk to white suburban voters
they're the ones who really matter why
because you recognize that this contract
is already unlocked y'all not gonna
leave no matter how much we neglect you
so I'm a focus on the people the new
people that we need to really win you
are and as long as that's the case they
can get away with saying stuff like yes
imagine him saying this about you
imagine him saying that about how it
would pass on the media trail we've
already seen happen where politicians
miss speak about and ends their career
he would be canceled so why is that
because they don't play with their
voting power they don't play with their
lobbying power
it is what it is we're gonna let it
happen again and again and again that's
the thing already know the habits so
we'd have to jump out of that pocket hmm
we have to do that we have to do a
better thing and I'm sympathetic I
understand that you may be looking at
this election like Yale this Trump may
really hurt me some people believe that
some people don't some people I can't
wait for Trump I'm ready but some people
look at it like he's really gonna hurt
me and as someone who's already living
on on the bottom or struggling in some
type of way I don't want that way to
come so I'm gonna just vote for Joe and
I get that I understand but at some
point you have to make the difficult
decision to aspire to something bigger
at some point you have to make the tough
choice and recognize and you may suffer
now so you know your kids don't have to
suffer later you may have to suffer now
so that you can set in place a new type
of infrastructure don't be offended now
if you're still gonna vote them because
all that is just noise it's just noise
you know what vote for who you want for
I'm not gonna tell anybody what to do my
thing is this people need to stop
listening to what politicians say and
start listening to how they move because
how they move is a real reflective real
reflection of how they're going to
govern their track records tell you a
lot about how they like to vote and
where they like to go that's all you got
to do stop stop tell me Joe Biden can
you believe you said that yeah but what
did he do what policies didn't act I
don't care how many black babies he
kisses on the campaign trail what has he
done to ensure that young black children
in inner city have good access to
education nothing
so all this grandstanding in front of
cameras if you fall for that that's your
fault I actually don't care if a black
person votes for Trump I don't if you
actually know why you're voting for him
and why it is that you vote for him yeah
and you've studied this I don't care if
you just vote for the person because
they they look like you already think
are they sadee think like you
you should watch em yeah so anyway so
that's pretty much it for today's video
I know you guys wanted us to come here
and explain why that statements hurtful
and look I can understand I did it yeah
someone say you're not black if you do
this it basically like who are you to
question my racial identity based off of
me trying to be an individual people do
it man do it it's fair but I think the
bigger issue here is what we talked
about earlier it's what he didn't say
watch that interview and tell me if he
said anything concrete tell me if he
ever addressed the fact that his track
record with african-americans is
actually bad tell me if he ever just
never so me I'm like miss me with all
that [ __ ] I see what's happening and
I'm just not gonna fall for it so a
little other side note we got a live
stream that we're gonna be doing weekly
here on YouTube so be sure to check our
YouTube stories to know when and on
Wednesday 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time we do
an Instagram live where if you guys want
to jump in on the camera and ask us
questions from your own cell phone you
can so Instagram subscribe to the a band
preach Instagram follow it you want to
get that info and also on a Friday
nights eastern time at midnight we are
well it's actually from the night of
Friday to Saturday we have the release
of the podcast the preach yawns have it
before so subscribe to the patreon if
you want to have this before yeah so
that's pretty much it peace that's
pretty much all I thought the only thing
else we said what we said all right let
us know what you guys think in the
comments below we want to hear your
thoughts
[Music]
you know it's a lot of right-wing media
outlets they question you they question
your cognitive health they don't they
don't think everything's working
upstairs what do you say to that I said
can hardly wait to meet with that guy
who is the stable genius